hello and welcome to this video
displaying chess Indian and going for
petrov again most people take only five
that's really the most popular reply
yeah this is not good at all but it's
let's say I have not yet looked at it
you can by the way played this hear a
funny transposition and the best is to
take and play of six but I don't know
this line so I'm transposing to this
which is a bit easier to play and also
of course fine for black yeah now Bishop
d3 take Bishop d6 is equal and that's
not the refutation of Bishop c4 if you
take on c3 + f6 this is almost refuted
but this is something I have not yet
studied and it is notoriously tricky so
I avoided it in this game yeah this
position is probably just about equal
while usually play something like rook
e1 d3 just being quite solid there in
the center
yeah I don't know take back yeah maybe
you wanted to play these three we don't
mind to grunt the take back if it really
looks like a mouse load the issue is I
mean if you started such a video it
should be some kind of instructive thing
and if they play something that is a bit
ridiculous because they made a mouse
slap the game yeah it's just a less
interesting game okay I was thinking
before I can take and play Bishop c4 huh
that isn't actually that great
should see foam
[Music]
maybe does it do anything just doesn't
make more sense I came okay I wonder
this this could be slightly slightly
annoying actually appears bit of a
nuisance I mean I don't think I'm in big
trouble or anything but looks a little
bit odd
I already should learn how this works
now with this night takes III and f6
people shouldn't get away with most like
Bishop C form it's just an incorrect
gambit but I know it's very tricky I
mean I can show you one or two things
after the after the game has finished
yeah I'm a bit under pressure
indefinitely I may be Bishop before even
oops
ouch I can take it that's lucky I did
not really have this on the radar at all
okay yeah we Queen f5 is not a big issue
here doesn't threaten all that much I
think it still plays that okay Queenie
r7 assist mostly just a check
it's possible though that it's still
dangerous
yeah I don't see it to be honest I mean
what's the deal
check me once and then what don't see it
just don't see it Bishop takes I can
even take with the Queen I don't see why
not
we can check on a jet bishop g8 and
whatever Bishop age 7 but I have Queen
age five and that's saving me easily
okay so I can check here and the gap
between f7 which is relatively easy or I
have King to f7 that also would work
twin g8 is made though that that means I
cannot just play my queen is hanging
okay I have to check this first and then
I have to make the choice if I want to
play Queen to f7 or if I want to play
King to have some king to f7 is probably
Bishop g8 Russia a drupe d7 okay so I
have to play the Queen it was a big but
I took it took a bit too long for this
conclusion but
preventing Bishop c4 for the moment okay
if I take it no there's no checkout
fortunately got two seconds
I was too slow now you should really do
that like lose on time increment you
shouldn't do that in a normal position
okay I was bit of a gift at the end yeah
I have to look this up really this is
basically here this is basically the
refutation but it's it leads to
immensely wacky positions with this g 6f
for like the engines giving it is good
for black but i have never looked at it
and i didn't feel like doing this over
the board in a blitz game the cisterns
posing to the to the four knights and
which is also an argument against this
because I care this is the other move
order and this is of of course
completely fine for black its equal
though so you're not punishing white for
the bishop see formal and equal is
exactly what we got him that is a very
normal disposition I think which is
equal I thought I felt deform I have
this move but it doesn't really work I
can even take but even if he plays rook
e1 there's nothing I don't have anything
I was somehow thinking that I had some
no yeah but discovering itself doesn't
work and this is now a little bit
annoying because I have this f6 move and
it's a little bit it's a bit unstable
yeah
so here have to be quite alert or I can
take on h2 because of Queen c7 check
that sucks
can just wind upon him because if he
takes him okay oh yeah so Bishop f7 is
bad and now I'm a little bit of trouble
queen of three means is seven queen of
five yeah the engine loves white maybe
there is something I didn't see it I
really didn't see it so Queen age seven
immediately and now Bishop to d3
okay so intending this and Bishop c4
okay and it seems that according to the
engine I don't have a particularly great
defense to that the engines line here
this this this is basically lost well
maybe not the Queen has no square
huh this is interesting this could be by
the way that could be a situation where
the computer is overestimating wider but
it's possible because the queenís is
simply not going anywhere
the problem could be that white might
pry open the position somehow to to to
enter with the rook and then it could
free himself free itself the Queen now
anyway I was under pressure there for
sure out here it felt okay I cannot take
on the wonders and made here so Queen no
I didn't think that was possible the ng
no ever says it is okay I did not see
absolutely not that I can go here and
it's not brilliant okay but I just
didn't see the opportunity or I didn't
see the possibility even existed to play
like that
so Queen f7 came here it's probably
roughly equal six and it's it's equal
you sure you should just play whatever
there's nothing much going on I'm not
threatening to win the Queen anytime
soon and I cannot so easily maneuver my
pieces so that I could I can not even a
ticket so now so it's just equal okay
guys thanks for watching